mr. McCarthy you look terrible
yeah you gotta get me out of here they
just hand me up with this new cellmate
is that my shirt this this shirt is that
my shirt no it looks like a shirt I own
no it looks like a shirt that you owned
what mr. McCarthy when you hired me as
your counsel you told me to take care of
all of your life's affairs and that
means things like your shirt I don't
need you to attend to my clothes tell
that to your chinos right these pleats
have never been crisper look at this I
could cut myself Hey what I am not
paying you to wear my chinos no you're
not you're paying me 250 dollars an hour
for legal fees the clothes wearing is
free complimentary you can tip look I
don't need anything complimentary what I
need is free to work on my case okay so
we can just leave it at that and of
course of course I've actually been
doing a lot of research I think you're
gonna be pleased okay what is that what
well is that uh this is a drawing your
child did okay what my son drew this is
that you are you holding hands with him
yeah it's an artistic Liberty he tuck we
weren't actually holding hands I was
kind of holding him like a koala what
why is my kid drawing pictures of you
that sounds like a question for him yeah
but if you have to no I got it when I
went over to your house why why are you
going to my house I have to go to your
house to take care of your clothes and
your couch and your HBO Go account
have you seen true detective no do I
know yeah they're movie stars don't go
to my house I hear you loud and clear
I'm just trying to do a couple couple
extra things like I got I got your car
fixed I mean you approve of that right
there was nothing wrong with my car what
yeah and I drove drunk look don't just
don't ever drive my car again okay fine
I'll have I'll have Helen give me a ride
my wife yes Helen your wife mount st.
Helen Helen of Troy Helen on wheels you
my wife what are you my wife
what no mr. McCarthy I'm appalled I
would never take advantage of you in
that way I do not your wife all right
thank God we make love
tender forgiving real boys to mention